Andie, will you hit a few headlines with us?
We are on the news.
Certainly, I'll do the best I can.
USA Today reports that many women actually love
their relaxed lockdown look so much that they plan
to keep them for good and people have been cutting down
on makeup, shaving, and hair products and feeling liberated
and ready to ride the less-is-more philosophy
into the sunset.
People are taking a more casual approach since the pandemic.
Andie, what do you have to say about this?
Well, you know, there's a couple of ways of looking at it.
Like, you know, for instance, I obviously,
I stopped coloring my hair but I don't know
what's going to happen in five years.
I may color my hair again, but I'm enjoying it right now
and what happened was I wasn't coloring my hair
and it was like half-colored back here
and then you could see my roots
and my daughters kept telling me that I looked bad-ass
and the idea that I could look bad-ass really appealed
to me, so I went for it, and I'm enjoying it,
you know, it's, I'm salt and pepper.
It's silver, I always correct people.
It's not gray, it's silver, but
(chuckling) It matters.
But I'm enjoying it right now
and it's not that I'm letting myself go.
I don't think of that, think of it that way.
I think of it like the first, when I first did it,
I went to the grocery store, 'cause we, you know,
we have no place to go and I thought I looked good.
So I went to the grocery store and I saw a man there
with a silver fox guy, you know, a guy that you register
and go, "Oh, he's a silver fox."
Mm-hm.
Immediately, just put my shoulders back, and I was like,
"And so am I," you know?
(laughs)
(inaudible) We both just like shot a look to each other.
I was like, "I'm a silver fox."
So it's, that's where I am right now.
Well, you look great.
But I think people are going to come back
like the roaring twenties.
I do, I think, I think you, is that what you've been saying?
Yes. I feel that.
I believe that, Andie, and you're like the first person
I've heard that and I'm with you.
Yeah.
I agree, I hope.
Our people are going to come back
and we're going to be so glamorous
and we're going to be dressing up,
Yeah.
And we're going to be doing,
just wanting to be with each other.
I think we're going to party like crazy people.
I think so, too.
We are going to look fabulous.
(inaudible) Makeup and you know, just have a blast.
I don't like this whole trend of though,
like letting quote, letting things go.
I think you look great with your hair.
That's not letting go.
But this idea of like, you know, no waxing, no this,
no that, I think you do need to whip yourself together
every once in a while.
For me, it helps keep me out of a funk, you know?
Yeah.
If I get up, if I get showered, if I look pretty,
I'll tell you this, I haven't had a real pedicure
in like 10 months?
I feel like a Pilgrim.
I'm doing it myself.
(laughs)
No more.
I can't wait for things to get back to normal.
I wish I would've come out of quarantine
looking like Andie McDowell.
By the way, I know.
Right?
I just, I've, you're always so beautiful,
and just once again, you're the most beautiful woman,
and if that's silver, gosh, I want silver,
and speaking of silver, silver foxes,
there's a story about Maye Musk, excuse me, Ross.
Please take it away.
Oh, so, well you know, Elon Musk's mom, you know,
he makes the Tesla and everything.
Oh yeah, everything.
Everything.
She just wrote a new book, and in it, she says
that she could tell that Elon was a genius
when he was three years old.
And in the memoir, she talks about all her kids.
But can you imagine having a three-year-old
and being like, "Okay, yeah, that one's a genius."
My mom used to say that she knew I was gay
when I was three years old but she never said anything
about being a genius, so.
(Drew laughs)
But do you think when you meet your kid at three years old
you can say, "I kind of think I know
who you're going to be?"
Yeah, Andie, you have such extraordinary daughters.
What were they like at three?
First of all, I think it's okay
to have just normal children, I will say,
because we can't (inaudible)
(Drew laughs)
Extraordinarily genius but my kids were very verbal.
Like, I'll meet kids and I'll see them and they don't,
they don't have conversations,
but mine were actually having conversations at three.
I don't want to sound braggy, but they did.
I think I expected them to have conversations at three,
so they're very verbal.
So I would say that was how they excelled was being,
you know, just being able to have a conversation,
like an adult conversation at an early age.
As excited as I get
that Maye Musk knew her son Elon was a genius,
I started thinking, my kids at three, I feel like the moment
in "Parenthood" when Rick Moran is looking
at Steve Martin's kid, like bang his head into a wall
with a bucket on his head and being like,
"You must be very proud."
(others laugh)
That's me with my kids, so I'm with you, Andie, I agree.
And speaking of being with you, Andie, please come back
and your beautiful movie,
"No Man's Land" is available right now.
Thank you, guys.
Happy Groundhog's Day!
Yes, Happy Groundhog's Day tomorrow!
Let's get it right!
(upbeat music)